what about his reputation what do you
think about all these interviews
um do you think they are helping him do
you think they're good for the world do
you think they're bad for the world like
what's your sense and like say you get
to sit down interview with him for three
hours
and I'm holding the door closed what uh
what kind of is that a useful
conversation or not or at this point it
should be legal and that's it I think
it's useful I mean I think with resp
it's all it's all about how you
interview them you can interview someone
responsibly you can interview him
irresponsibly I think we've seen
examples of both what's in irresponsible
I keep interrupting you rudely that's
okay no no unacceptable no no I think
it's fine
um there was like a New York Times
interview which
spends an amount of time any amount of
time talking about his sleep and he's
like yeah I'm sleeping great I mean I
think that's so deeply disrespectful to
the victims and especially when you're
you're not even releasing an interview
live it's like you have time to triage
what you're going to talk about why
would you spend any amount of time
talking about the sleep that a fraudster
is get get it's just so weird and well
let's do it can I steal man in that case
I don't I don't I don't think it turned
out I think that's I think that's I I
think okay here's the thing
I could see myself talking about
somebody's sleep or getting in
somebody's mind if I knew I have
unlimited time with them if I knew I had
like a four hours because you get into
the minds of the person how they think
how they see the world because I think
that ultimately reveals
if they're actually really good at lying
it reveals the depths the complexity of
the mind that through like osmosis you
get to understand like this person this
person is not as trivial as you realize
also makes you maybe realize that this
person is has a lot of Hope has a lot of
positive ambition that's like uh that
has developed over their life and then
certain interesting ways things went
wrong yeah it become corrupt and all
that kind of stuff you just that's all
fine but this was this conversation was
not properly contextualized yes in the
world of what he did
it and I you know I've I've asked about
this interview because I was like so
curious it was out of the New York Times
and there was not much mention of fraud
or jail or the the big crimes like
misappropriation of even client assets
it was just sort of this you know Sam
sat down with me he's he's under
investigation but there's not much
specifics and then it's like yeah he's
playing storybook brawl he's sleeping
he's and it's just like okay this isn't
adding to the conversation especially in
the New York Times it's like uh you
should be grilling right right exactly
so
um but as I said I mean it's all range
the gamut and some interviews like some
of it's okay and then some of it's weird
like the Andrew Sorkin interview he
asked some hard-hitting questions which
I really appreciated and then at the end
he goes ladies and gentlemen Sam Beekman
freed and everyone gives like a like an
ovation for
Sam I mean the Steel Man of that of
course is like they're actually
applauding Andrew Sorkin but the way you
like lay it up I wouldn't go like ladies
and gentlemen it's like an Applause line
it's like ladies and gentlemen the
Eagles Elton John Lex Friedman and so to
go to so you have this like deal book
Summit where you have all these
important figures that are positively
important and at the end you have Sam
bankman free to fraudster and yo ladies
and gentlemen Sam McMan freed everyone's
applauding that I think is a net like I
think that's a negative I think the way
that the Optics of that just were all
wrong and so I think um yeah you have to
be very responsible
I think it's useful going back to how
you can usefully do this
you can even when somebody's determined
to lie to you
It's always important to
pin them down to a an accounting of
events because that is unimaginably
helpful when it comes to a prosecutor
trying to prove this guy's guilty is
if you say you didn't do a crime but you
don't tell me any details about it
day of the trial you can basically make
up any story right but if you tell me in
detail where you were that day I can go
hunt down you say you were with Joe I go
hunt down Joe and he says he wasn't with
you boom you've lost credibility and now
you're much more you're much more likely
to be convicted so it's really important
to get sbf's exact accounting of how
things went wrong because right now he's
positioning himself to throw his uh
Alameda CEO Caroline Ellison under the
bus like she did everything she knew
everything I knew nothing
well as Caroline Ellison's going to take
the stand and go well I have all these
text messages and this is all a lie and
then Sam begman freed is going to be
completely
you know
uh ruined like self-ruin by his own
design so I think it's more like a legal
type of uh like get the details of where
he was what he was thinking what the I
think it's like yeah I think it's
it's public probably cares to get to
know what happened to and again I think
if you're if you're careful
you can expose someone for as they lie
to you without giving in to those lies
right like without capitulating to oh
I'm just going to assume you're correct
I think you can point to well Lex you
say it happened this way but you've lied
about X Y and Z why should we believe
you that's a suddenly a totally
different conversation than just being
like Oh okay that's how it happened the
thing I caught that bothered me
and the thing I hope to do in interviews
of
um if if I eventually get good at this
thing is the human aspect of it which is
like which I think you have to do in
person
is he seems a bit nonchalant about the
pain and the suffering of people
that I have red flags about in the way
he's he communicates about the loss of
money like the pain that people are
feeling about the money I I get red
flags like you're not uh forget if
you're involved in that pain or not
you're not
feeling that pain
well he'll he'll say he is but he'll be
playing a game of League of Legends
while doing it no but I just see it from
his face
needs to be grilled yeah like that
little human dance there that's I mean I
um I considered
I talked to him I considered doing an
in-person interview with him
um
and you know are you still considering
it
I don't know do you think do you think I
I should in person I think it depends if
you think you have anything to add to
the conversation a lot of people have
yeah there's been already you did an
incredible job thanks
I think I I think I would like to grill
the [ __ ] out of them as a fellow human
yeah but not investigating no coffees
they'll investigative yeah yeah like
like another human being another human
being who I can have compassion for who
has caused a lot of suffering in the
world
like that that grilling like basically
convey the anger that people and the
pain that people are feeling
right like that yeah
I think
I think it'd be really hard I mean like
that guy is sort of a master dancer and
what he would say at the end of it
because I've listened to so many
interviews of him
um I probably am like a GPT model for
Sam
I think he would do some kind of thing
about like yeah I really um I really um
hear you and um you know it's it's just
terrible I feel such an obligation to
the people who've lost money and you
know it's just it's a lot of money it's
a lot of money you know you do something
like that and it would be very
superficially like okay
but when you gr when you drill down to
the details of what he did it's just
impossible that he didn't know and one
of the things that I wish I had asked
maybe I can talk about like I wish I had
gone on this it's just so hard when
you're doing a live interview to kind of
focus on one thing
everyone's asked about the terms of
service so in the terms of service there
was like
we can't touch your funds your funds are
safe we're never going to do anything
with that anytime anyone brings that up
he says oh well there's this other term
disservice over here with margin trading
accounts remember we talked about it's a
derivatives platform if you're in our
derivative side
you have you're subject to different
terms of service which kind of lets us
like move your money around with
everyone else okay
so we treat it as one big pool of funds
and that's sort of the explanation of
how this all happened is we had this
huge leverage position and we lost
everything
but what no one has sort of done a good
enough job getting to the heart of is
that this pool of funds never was
segregated properly it was all treated
under the same umbrella of we can use
your funds there was no amount of we
have the client deposits which were just
deposited with us and not like used to
margin trade or do anything over here
These funds over here we have saved they
didn't fundamentally they lied from the
get-go about how they were treating the
most precious assets which is your
customer deposits that you said you
didn't invest clearly you put them all
over here you YOLO gambled them and then
when everyone starts withdrawing from
here they don't have any money over here
so that is like one of the most
fundamental things that I haven't seen
anyone Grill him on and uh the next time
if I get the chance to Ambush them again
that's that's what I'm going to drill
down on because it's impossible for that
not to be fraud
there's no world where you had a pool of
funds over here and now you don't have
them without you somehow borrowing over
here because if you deposited one
Bitcoin and I never sold that Bitcoin
and it's earmarked Lex Friedman and you
come and it's not there something had to
happen right well it says this is so
interesting so for me
the approach that like you said the most
important question of uh because for you
it's like were those funds segregated
for me the question is as a human being
how would you feel if you were observing
that so like
you know that like marshmallow test with
the babies like it's the human thing
it's a human nature question like uh I
can understand there's a pile of money
and you uh
the good faith interpretation is like
well I know what to do with that pile of
money to grow that pile of money let me
just take a little bit of that
like how willing are you to do that kind
of thing how able are you to do that
kind of thing and when [ __ ] goes wrong
what goes through your mind how does it
become corrupted how do you begin to
Lose Yourself how do you uh delegate
responsibility for the failures like as
opposed to getting facts
try to sneak into the human Mind of a
person when they're thinking that
because the facts there's they're start
gonna start waffling they're gonna start
like trying to make sure they don't say
anything that gets them incriminated
right but I just I want to understand
the human being there because I think
that indirectly gives you a sense of
where were you in this big picture I
think I've talked to so many people who
have sort of committed some range of
like outright fraud to like misleading
marketing
no one thinks they're a bad person
nobody admits that they did it and they
knew they are almost nobody does there's
actually one funny exception but um
you had a guy who admitted like yeah I
did it it was wrong and uh you know but
I did it and I wanted the money which
was kind of like almost refreshing in
its honesty but um the reason I focus on
like the facts is because
unless you find a bright red line
humans can rationalize anything I can
rationalize any level of like well I did
this because I had the best of
intentions and if you play the intention
game you'll never convict anyone because
everyone has good intentions everyone's
honest everyone's doing the best they
can and got misleaded and got misguided
ultimately you have to drill down to the
concrete and go look
I get it you're just like the last 50
guys that I interviewed you had the best
of intentions it all went wrong I'm very
sorry for you but at the end of the day
there's people hurting and there's
people that have significant damage to
their life because of you what did you
actually do and what can we prove taking
intention out of it taking motivation
out what can we prove that you did that
was unethical illegal or immoral and
like that is
sort of what usually I try to go to
because I will do those human interviews
but
um you know it's just like it's just
it's like the same record on repeat I
mean a lot I got it the same I I'm with
you I'm with you on the everything you
said but there is ways to do
to avoid the record and repeat I mean
those are different skill set you're
exceptionally good at the investigative
like investigating I do believe there's
a way to break through the the repeat
there's the different techniques to it
yeah one of which is like taking outside
of their particular story yes EV when
everyone looks at their own story they
can see themselves as a good player
doing good but you can do other thought
experiments I mean there's uh but
they'll follow you they'll know what the
thought experiment is no well it depends
it depends my friend I mean the like uh
you know to me there's a million of them
but of just exploring your ethics would
you kill somebody to protect your family
and you explore that you start to sneak
into like what's your sense uh of the
in-group versus the owl group
how much damage you can do to the out
group and who is the out group and you
start to build that sense of the person
are we like the two Mobsters that we're
dressed as do we protect the family and
[ __ ] everyone else you're with us and
the ones who are against us [ __ ] them or
do we have a sense that human human all
human beings are all have value equal
value and we want to wear a join
Humanity there's ways to get to that and
you start to build up this sense of like
some people that make a lot of money are
better than others they deserve to be at
the Top If you have that feeling you
start to get get a sense of like yeah
the poor people are the dumb asses
they're the idiots if you believe that
then you start to understand that this
person may have been at the core of this
whole corrupt organization to yes two
things one
I think you should join me on this side
of the table we'll put SPF over here
yeah well good guy bad guy human facts
like you're the bad guy I'm like no no
slow down coffee what is your feeling
about Humanity
yeah have you been getting enough sleep
yeah right obviously so I so I think no
I think there's a lot of Truth to what
you said
one thing I've noticed that is hard to
combat is sort of like preference
falsification and just like just the
outright lying about those things is
tough to kind of pin down but yeah
you're absolutely right there's ways to
interview people there's all sorts of
interesting techniques and yeah I don't
disagree good good cop bad cop we should
do this should be like a sitcom okay